g6 okay
at least it's not kind of
let's try to do something strange here
let's go bishop c4 maybe
this should be three
then we'll just castle and just
okay
so the point of what i'm doing is that
basically i'm playing the
english opening with bishop c5
uh having an extra tempo
which is not that important but it's uh
very playable anyway
the white is normally sort of trying to
get e4 e5 here
and black has many plans he can play e5
he can also try some 97 followed by
yeah 97 followed by some c5 c4 e1
eventually
okay
yeah knight c5 logical so what should i
play now i can play this page six
e4 doesn't win yet i have bishop c4
right so i can
maybe he could just take and then play
something
logical starts with a4 takes eggs
do i need to take one
yeah it's not that i dramatically need
to take it almost
without a hand why not today okay let's
take it again
only bishop is six now i will probably
take and do something something before
check
or even e5 straight away you can also
play rook a2d one first
yeah let's do the one first
so in general it kind of shows
ob6 that allows knight takes c4 but not
exe4
doesn't make a lot of can also play
queen before check
now he has e5 but it's quite unlikely
i can also just play b3 so b3 would be
my first intention
yeah again somewhere somewhere okay
let's just go b string
it's still a bit mysterious i can manage
to
trade a lot of pieces in the 8-balls but
why exactly is it
an achievement for black people
cb was kind of considerable as well but
i just like this one more so now i guess
i can play
queen before check and then you fight
finally
you'll probably play f6 so
i can start by playing e5 and then clean
this three
yeah it kind of makes sense
yeah now he has a d5 which is annoying
this is
this is logical okay then we'll probably
restrict your coupon code like h4 and so
on
h5 start to like the list
okay let's say rupees three
in terms of ideas it looks logical to
play something like rookie 392 to d4
yeah i guess now i'm 92
and then i want some f4 followed by
five
that also requires him to
yeah to spend like three months doing
nothing to be honest but
there is always a hole
i think rook v2 e6 followed by rookie
one makes sense here
he goes okay too not exactly attacking
anything so i just go with four
now at least it starts to make sense for
white
like i really want to play five gtx and
then some rookie phone on edge
three
the old queen is seven so who takes
these three is just right now
fencing okay i got kimberly
we need five let's go
so what should i do i don't really want
to trade the queens
on the other hand
who really cares about what i want here
i could play rook c3 probably before and
it takes seems to work
okay let's try it
feels a bit shaky some room before
kind of make sense i don't know queen
before that prevents
f5 after release he also wants to play
d4
he's actually smart and
let's just pick ministry
before now that we have an increment
it's now that i'm
like dramatically scared of losing
confinement
now f5 is coming maybe he should play
queen b to face it with f6
he goes to d6 i think the laws are fine
now that the fight is unique immediately
though but
at least i have some engines so f6 now
can i do it i don't know
let's try it takes
wow this allows many things in the seven
g3 was also fine but yeah okay this is
nice
aerial turnover yeah
okay same problem
groups less okay